[Music]
you know sam i just got some sweet news
dude
are you telling me you just got sweet
news yeah i uh
met someone who works on the avatar
sequels production and she was like we
all saw the avatar 2 video apparently
someone shared it in like the production
slack and they were like hey everybody
get out of the way
[Laughter]
honestly
the news that they have seen it is kind
of embarrassing in fact i made it almost
with the intention that no one would
ever see it they liked it
is this is this because it's so bad that
it's funny we're just wanting to make
sure that this is like
positive supportive laughter not not you
know
i don't want to be cyber bullied by the
avatar 2 crew basically
yeah no pressure but like i'm pretty
sure they all are
gonna watch this next thing
the avatar 2 crew
is counting on me
to prove myself
hi i'm sam gorski creator of avatar 2.
well that is until james cameron
finishes his official version today i
just learned that all eyes in hollywood
are finally on me that means with my
next motion capture project i'm gonna
have to prove to the world that i know
what i'm doing and if i can't
well
i promise to never wear a motion capture
suit again and uninstall unreal engine
from all computers in the studio never
to be opened again
and i mean that
the stakes have never been higher
it's
2021 that means it's been nearly one
year of you guys having to endure my
motion capture experiments that's right
it's been a year since i learned unreal
engine since i became obsessed with
real-time virtual production and you've
seen that journey video game characters
react clint's vr meditation zone avatar
2 handsome squidward all of those videos
have one thing in common
they're janky they're full of problems
and because of that jank well i'm not
gonna lie i feel like i owe you
a good video with motion capture and
unreal engine if i can't deliver on that
i should probably stop i don't know how
much more you can take at this
today as the proving grounds for whether
or not my career ends we are going to
shoot a video called the cut scene it's
a video about a character who gets
trapped in a cut scene where suddenly
they become mortal it's that joke haha
cutscene starts someone takes out a gun
oh don't shoot despite you know taking a
thousand bullets in the level before so
that's the video concept nico and myself
will act in it we're gonna have two
motion capture suits we have my pc down
here with all the stuff set up facial
capture we have that finally down now
every single element that we're going to
be doing here today has been tested in
the past the handsome squidward video
was actually the first moment where we
saw a glimpse of what a full smooth
successful mocap performance could look
like there's even some things we've
learned since then to make it even
better i think i got this figured out
finally and if i don't my career is over
so it doesn't matter
okay now that all the eyes of hollywood
are upon sam i i i'm a little concerned
about his mental state you know this
might bring on a lot of pressure onto
him and if there's one thing i think he
doesn't need it's any more eyes on him
so i'm gonna call him right now oh boy
hey jake perfect timing hey man
so i i heard that all the eyes of
hollywood are upon you yeah they are uh
but it's no big deal do you
really so you're feeling pretty good
about it uh-huh i think i'm gonna blow
them away well yeah sam but i mean
there's definitely eyes that you don't
want on you right like you know internet
service providers hackers and so i just
wanted to let you know about today's
sponsor expressvpn sam expressvpn those
guys are great i love them one thing
that they can do for you
is secure your internet privacy
basically the vpn serves as an
encryption to all of the data that goes
from your computer out onto the internet
and vice versa which just means that
there's gonna be way less eyes upon you
wow
wow
did you also know that expressvpn does
content unblocking unblocking content i
know after you've had a long day one
thing you like to do is sit down and
watch the old ball game oh yeah the ball
game is usually where you can find me
when i'm not here at my computer if you
do not have a certain subscription to a
certain cable network in los angeles you
cannot watch the dodgers baseball team
that's that's terrible well what you can
do is with an expressvpn subscription
you can tell platforms like mlb tv that
you're you're viewing from uh you know
say dallas and that'll that'll allow you
to watch the dodgers even though you are
local to la and you don't have said
cable network subscription wow so you're
telling me i can watch baseball
in texas
expressvpn allows you to do this in any
sport on any platform wherever you're
experiencing local blackouts i mean sam
they're one of the fastest vpn services
out there they've been rated number one
vpn by platforms like techradar so head
on over to
expressvpn.com corridor crew
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
or crew and you can find out how you can
get three months free go to
expressvpn.com corridor crew thanks jake
i mean sam i i can't wait to see
everything you're working on thanks i'm
glad to show you i'm happy to share it
with you really appreciate that call see
you later jake bye bye bye
[Music]
my role in this shoot is i'm going to be
hanging out kind of man in the chair
situation i got my audio set up to
record audio of everybody and i got my
official capture i got my motion capture
peter was responsible for capturing the
motion capture that was his job for the
day he lost an entire day of footage
yeah he's got a great track record which
is why he's the trusted man for the job
i [ __ ] us
and so now he gave me another shot this
is kind of my redemption story
if you will so we're in our imaginations
right now and we're going to imagine
that we're cool guys in a warehouse
basically we only have two actors that
have to fill the role of like 12
characters
all right
scene 1a rambo three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
cool
so there's a tower
it's got four sides and then moving
along the edge a little bit to like line
up a shot
and then boom
i didn't think about this i could just
use an imaginary gun i suppose
i can't
i can't do anything here
three two one action
[Applause]
nice try
[Laughter]
everything is going surprisingly well i
mean there's a little bit of drink here
and there but it's nothing that we can't
reprocess and clean up later like it's
just kind of like you're like gun cut
it's like in real life we're like all
right next shot's up on the hill
everyone carries the gear up the hill
here we're just like cut all right uh
next take go and we're like oh cool
we're in a whole new place we're
literally different characters there's
no like oh hey get the stuntman out of
his trailer bring him down to set you
know you're waiting 15 minutes for a guy
to walk like no none of that happens
here it's just literally the endurance
of wearing mocap suits
this mocap helmet is
wildly uncomfortable
this is painful in fact so you might
notice like on the avatar set or other
motion capture scenarios their face rigs
don't look like this they don't have
phones here they just have cameras that
are either recording like infrared data
people have like facial dots or stuff
like that those rigs require way less
gear way less weight they're not quite
invisible but they are compared to this
you know when you have to have a phone
mounted in front of you that ends up
being
a lot of leverage and weight and so
while it's a great
way to capture your facial performance
it's not the best one for when you have
to
like don an entire suit
and then then actually do some you know
big scene the phone ends up being a
better device to get your facial
performance afterwards instead of you
know in the moment
it's the ending scene
the big scene with the big acting where
nico gets to lie on his couch they say
never work with babies and animals turns
out we can just use computers to save
that from everything issue
nice and cozy there you go
please tell me the story about how you
killed all the bad guys again
shot a lot of them with my big old gun
until
well one day i had to run away from it
all but what happened to all the bad
guys then i probably went on to chase
other heroes your stories make me so
sleepy oh oh [ __ ]
good kid he's a good kid right there
[Laughter]
so we've done all our mocap
nico and myself are all the characters
in the video now we have to get it
looking nice we have to render it out we
have to do camera angles how do we get
to that stage where we're rendering it
there's a bunch of steps along that
process they're hard to figure out as
you're doing them but they're pretty
simple in hindsight so this is what you
get out of the motion capture suit you
basically just get a like a random
looking skeleton guy there's just the
body movement there's no facial
performance so the face is actually
running and recording into a separate
application iclone is the animation arm
of the character creator world so you
have your body but now you have your
face and we get to combine the
animations once you have this data
thankfully it's pretty easy to hop
between different types of characters in
character creator there's a lot of
options for creating full characters
everything skin clothes whatever you can
also go to the unreal marketplace
and get a bunch of cool characters that
are rigged there and you take all that
data throw it on a body and then you get
to watch it do its thing
hey who's that that's nico that's the
animation but let's see what it looks
like in the actual scene boom now he's
actually in the scene this is actually
the most fun part once we've kind of
like gotten through that stage and the
animation's finally in here it's all fun
afterwards like there's no more like
technical crap we're dealing with here
it's all
like just the raw like filmmaking fun
energy here
[Music]
yeah man did you sleep here last night
yeah i'm almost done with the video i
thought it was gonna be easy once i set
up all the cameras and like rendered it
out but that's when i realized i was
just encountering the next wave of
problems
are you uh
what do you got this robe on for
but you still got the suit on did were
you doing mo cap stuff or a little bit
here and there
none no i wasn't doing any mocap i just
want to be prepared if someone tries to
like forcibly get rid of the mocap suit
and you know it'll be on my body i'll be
protecting it so look i've spent the
last year working on this stuff and
investing so much time and energy and
research into it that for it all to slip
away because of some stupid promise i
made i promise to never wear a motion
capture suit again and uninstall unreal
engine from all computers in the studio
i got problems to share i thought
once i put my cameras into the scene it
was going to be smooth sailing once i
started rendering those close-ups i saw
all the little problems and had to go
back through and tweak
almost everything facial expressions eye
lines hand movements positions etc
there's a lot of work
like this the issue here is that he's
looking straight ahead and that's that
makes sense in the moment because it's
niko and myself acting off of each other
we're you know generally the same height
the problem is is that the character
he's looking at is like a foot taller
than him so i basically go in find the
head bone and i literally just turn it
up and then he's looking up at the
taller character that's a really good
example of the tiny tweaks that have to
happen george lucas was one of the first
people to pioneer tweaking someone's
performance after it was filmed so i'm
really just carrying his legacy by doing
this
so
check it out you can see look at all
these shots look at these dope shots
just all these little shots here are
individual clips that i've rendered out
we have all the footage finally in
resolve here at first i was like this is
going to get really complicated because
you have 12 angles with perfect
continuity say you're not gonna shoot me
with a bullet are you sure am oh yeah
buddy do your best
i can take hundreds the big constraint
is the concept of perfect continuity in
normal filmmaking you do a scene and
you're like that was funny but i think
the last line should be maybe a little
more angry and so generally you'd just
be like hey just give me the last line
again but now i'm angry yeah okay anyway
cool cut we just what we'll drop that in
that's way harder to do when it's motion
capture because organizing the files
syncing everything inserting into the
scene there's only one scene in this
whole video that i'm blending
two performances from and the way i have
to do that is not by like splicing and
making the decisions in the sequence
itself but by constructing two full
versions of the scene i'm redoing an
entire sequence two times and rendering
all the camera angles out and then in
the edit i actually splice them together
it's pretty difficult the amount of work
required to get their adds up really
quickly it's definitely faster in real
life to do something like that but once
again it comes back to this core concept
here of this is like a stage play at
this point we want the performance to be
as good as possible in its entirety
after the last
month and a half of trying to get this
video going
i think it's finally at a point where
it's watchable it's it's a little
you know it's like it's a little weird
here and there but from a storytelling
perspective
you know
check it's dynamic enough to hold your
attention and make you pay attention to
the actual characters thank gosh we did
it because
i freaking
crashed into every freaking roadblock
with my truck the truck's damaged my
metaphorical truck is definitely damaged
but i have made it to the other side
am i ready to show everyone this video
yes
and with a medium degree of confidence
there's going to be some people out
there who
are going to try and rip the suit off my
body
but while wearing it i feel quite nimble
and i'll be able to escape them
displayed before us we have a motion
capture suit here that i must give up if
this isn't good we're throwing out the
motion capture suits and uninstalling
unreal yeah stepping stones are over
look if this works this has a ton of
promise and potential wouldn't it be
cool to shoot a video wherever you want
with actors that look however you want
that would be amazing can sam pull it
off man filming avatar 2 i had such high
expectations and
you know it was
it was a fun watch this one
i do have high expectations though
and
i don't know hopefully uh sam steps up
to them so we'll see no pressure
let me present to you a year of work and
i hope you guys like it here it is three
two one
go all right
let's do this
[Music]
[ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
that was awesome sweet that was very
awesome sweet it worked it worked
that's a relief to hear
so
i'm not quite sure i understand is this
a rough cut
the animations are
final exciting yeah the animation is
final
yeah what's wrong with that
i don't want to say it's trash
it's better than avatar too i don't know
if it should be on the internet at all
like it has its flaws but i think it's
good i just don't think it's there yet
and uh
i mean i think we have to uninstall
unreal no it's fine cool anyways i'm
glad you guys uh checked out that video
i'm really glad you guys saw the video
so i'm gonna head out um you can yeah
throw away my capsules
i don't i don't want to be here when you
i don't want to be here when you throw
them away because i'll be too sad so i
think i should head out so i don't
actually
[Applause]
hey buddy
you're gonna you're gonna have to rip it
off my body if you want it back it's
okay you can keep it on i just i just
wanted to say
i don't know why i said all that mean
stuff it was kind of mean it was just
like when they told me that they laughed
at me on the set of avatar too i i did
think the video was funny it made me
laugh were you like laughing at the
video or were you laughing at me i was
laughing at the video
i'm sorry except your apology you want
to come back inside i'll be honest i
actually really want to take this suit
off it's like super hot those things are
really tight yeah
what you're working on what are we doing
here oh boy i am working on some
original corridor digital anime nft
trading cards for you guys if you want
to own a little piece of corridor cannon
for those of you who are into nfts we
are going to be dropping the anime
collection which is our three anime
videos baseball fidget spinners and
anime self-driving cars but you know
what the thing is like when you have
single edition auctions it's not really
accessible to a bunch of people because
they're single editions so we've made
all these really cool digital playing
cards and they'll be like legendary
editions they'll be rare editions
combinations we got some sweet designs
we've been passing ideas back and forth
for days and we finally settled on
something that looks super sweet so i'm
excited for you guys to see it so this
wednesday the 19th and maker's place
these cars go live they're not all one
of one there's actually ideas to
actually make enough cars that they're
accessible if people want them anyways
i'm so excited for local xero to be
coming out next we are going to be
working on that it's going to be up on
our website quarterdigital.com
sam has realized the dream it's working
we're getting unreal animation actually
looking decent and like having
characters work and moves correctly and
it's a little janky but it's all set in
the video game so it works right all
right that's it so long everybody will
see in the next video